and you mentioned
o.j simpson before you know if the glove
doesn't fit
uh you must have quit it's going to be
you know just in in our lexicon
for probably a long time now so so it
happens
but that's not and and it shouldn't be
uh foremost on your mind
right what do you make uh what do you
make of those jason trout
do you do you have thoughts about it
he's uh
he's out and about on social media now
he's a public figure
is there uh lessons to be drawn from
that whole saga
well you know that was an interesting
case i was a young public defender i
want to say in my first year
as a public defender when that verdict
came out so that case was important
in so many ways one it was the first
dna case a major
dna case and there were significant
lessons learned from that
one mistake that the prosecution
made was uh that they didn't present the
science in a way
that a lay jury could understand it
um and uh what johnny cochran did was
he understood the science and was able
to
uh uh translate that
into a into a vocabulary that he
bet that that jury understood
uh so so cochrane was dismissive
of a lot of dna they said you know he
said something like oh
you know they say they found you know uh
such and such amount of dna that's just
like me you know wiping my finger
against my nose and
and and just that little bit of dna and
uh that was effective because the
prosecution hadn't done a good job of
establishing that
yes it's microscopic you don't need that
much
yes wiping your hand on your nose and
touching something you can transfer a
lot of dna and that gives you good
information
yeah but you know it was the first time
that the public generally
and that jury maybe since high school
science had heard you know
you know nucleotide i mean it was just
all these terms getting thrown
at them and and but it was not weaved
into
a narrative so uh cochrane taught us
that no matter what type of case it is
no matter what science is involved it's
still about
storytelling it's still about a
narrative and he was uh
and he was great uh at that at that
uh at that narrative and was consistent
uh with his narrative all the way out
uh another uh lesson that
uh was relearned uh it's that you know
you never
ask a question to what you don't know
the answer that's like
trial advocacy 101 yeah and so when they
gave
uh o.j simpson the glove and it wouldn't
fit
you know you don't you don't do things
where you just don't know how it's going
to turn out it was
way way too risky and then and and i
think that's what
acquitted him because that glove the
glove just wouldn't fit and he got to
do this and ham in front of the camera
and all of that and
uh and it was big do you think about do
you think about representation of
storytelling like you
yourself and your absolutely absolutely
we
tell stories it is fundamental we
uh since time and memorial we have told
stories to help us make sense
of the world around us so
as a scientist you tell a different type
of story
but we as a public have
told stories uh from time immemorial to
to to help us make sense of the physical
and the natural
uh world and uh we are still a
a a species that is moved by
storytelling so that that's first and
last in trial work you have to tell a
good
story um and you know the basic
introductory books about
trial work uh teach young students young
students and young lawyers to
to start in opening with this case is
about
this case is about and then you fill in
the blank and you know
that's your narrative that's the
narrative you're gonna you're gonna tell
and of course you can do the ultra
dramatic
the glove doesn't fit kind of the climax
and all those kinds of things
you